(audience cheers and applauds)
(upbeat music)
♪ Every time I think of you ♪
♪ I always catch my breath ♪
♪ And I'm still standing here ♪
♪ And you're miles away ♪
♪ And I'm wondering why you left ♪
♪ There's a storm that's raging ♪
♪ Through my frozen heart tonight ♪
♪ I hear your name in certain circles ♪
♪ And it always makes me smile ♪
♪ I spend my time ♪
♪ Thinking about you ♪
♪ And it's almost driving me wild ♪
♪ And there's a heart that's breaking ♪
♪ Down this long distance line tonight ♪
♪ I ain't missing you at all ♪
♪ Missing you ♪
♪ Since you've been gone away ♪
♪ I ain't missing you now ♪
♪ Missing you ♪
♪ No matter what my friends say ♪
♪ And there's a message
that I'm sending out ♪
♪ Like a telegraph to your soul ♪
♪ And if I can't bridge this distance ♪
♪ Stop this heartbreak overload ♪
♪ I ain't missing you at all ♪
♪ Missing you ♪
♪ Since you've been gone away ♪
♪ I ain't missing you ♪
♪ No, I ain't missing you ♪
♪ No matter what my friends say ♪
♪ I ain't missing you at all ♪
(audience cheers and applauds)
(applause overpowers voice)